[Music]
my name is Jack Weitzel and I manage
global partnerships or something in
Android that we call dedicated devices
I'll explain a little bit more about
what that is but for now you can think
about that as anything that's not a
smartphone right so all the other use
case that we'll talk about you know
falls into that category I want to have
a discussion today about a couple of
things yeah one I want to talk about why
we're why we're placed in the Android
why we're placing a focus on the
enterprise use cases how we're
addressing those use cases what's some
of the trends in industry that we've
seen regarding the use of mobile
operating systems and give you some
examples it's not shield custom use case
that's my favorite part
and what I hope to do is walk through
give some examples over we'll open up
the floor to questions afterwards in
case you have some observations
questions and and obviously happy to
talk more about that so I'm gonna start
out with a couple of numbers there's no
Google presentation that can be done
without numbers to start things off with
some of those numbers you may already
know
for example there's 2.3 billion monthly
active users on Android every month 2.3
2 billion devices that are used that are
GMs devices that's Google mobile
services you can think of that as Play
services everything they used to in a
mobile phone I'm gonna talk a little bit
more in detail why this is important but
I want to talk first off about what that
scale is just to give you an indication
no other operating system has ever
shipped 2.3 billion copies and that's
what we have monthly active users that
has a lot of implications as to what we
have to do for the ecosystem and how we
need to build it that also has
implications about what we're doing an
enterprise a key to that is Google Play
obviously with smartphones or enterprise
use cases enterprise devices require the
ability to install manage update various
applications on a device and it's just
massive there's about 84 sorry 94
billion apps were down 94 billion apps
were down in the last year we see about
8 billion installs every month so if you
think about that in order to manage that
and ensure security ensure usability
ensure consistency we've had to take all
that into consideration as we're
building out to support this ecosystem
and we're creating that ability to
address this that you could take
advantage of an enterprise with your
enterprise use cases now one set of
numbers you may not be aware of is the
fact that there will be about 300
million Android phones that were shipped
for business use this year that's just
for business use and we've broken down
because of how we address the market
into those that are personally liable
bring your own device or sometimes
corporate owned 227 million in in
personal liable and 60 million in
corporate owned now 78 percent of
devices 78 percent of all the devices
ship for business or Android devices so
that's a big why as to why we're
building out what used to be considered
kind of a consumer operating system and
quite frankly we went to we went to
market initially focused on consumers
until we saw a huge increase in the
business market and since lollipop we
spent an awful lot of time building and
capabilities to address enterprise these
cases know the reason that's important
is prior to this point there are lots of
entrepreneurs creating ways to manage
deploy utilize these devices and they
all into being proprietary and all ended
up fragmenting the marketplace we
recognized that there were there was a
that was contrary to everything else we
did Android number one I'd mentioned the
bit about compatibility and shirin
usability and so forth if you have
fragmentation like this that hurts
everybody across the ecosystem so we
decided to do starting lollipop is
really deliver in the platform the
ability to manage device in a consistent
fashion we take a look and see work
profile and fully managed that's a
scenario where a fully managed obviously
the corporation owns the device you know
work profiles where corporation owns a
folder on your device it's a separate
user complete data separation you know
for those use cases that's all I'm gonna
say about work profile because it's not
what this is this is about but those are
the two key pieces to the management
capability when we got to marshmallow
that's when we started really focusing
more on the enterprise use cases that
were different from a smartphone so we
introduced lock task mode the ability to
set devices up more
easily in kiosk mode so you can deploy
business use cases something that might
be unattended something will be
different than a smartphone scenario and
we've continued all through these next
couple of releases more and more
capabilities that were addressed they're
simply address the enterprise use cases
including being able to allow multiple
shifts for being able to log into a
device more easily instead of having to
manage all of that software in a very
awkward fashion we allow you sign in to
sign out with P with these various
devices that will apply to some of the
cuse cases I'll talk about in rugged as
well as any of the public facing
multi-user sessions that we talked about
the reason I'm putting all this out is
if you're looking at enterprise use case
and you're trying to figure out how to
blow all the applications that you want
you don't have to build that capability
we've got it addressed in the platform
you can focus on what's the value add
instead of just the base capability now
underlying all of this you know the open
the room by the way with a lot of
discussions I had early on when I joined
the Android team with security and and
this perception that Android was less
secure than other operating systems we
that's sort of been job number one and
Android making sure that we address that
through security updates other
capabilities that we do that'll touch on
in just a second but the pace of
security innovation has been massive in
fact so much so that Gartner tells us
that as of Oreo we actually surpassed
what they were seeing in iOS which was
typically considered a more secure
operating system than Android so the
pace has been huge it's not that others
haven't been invading as well we've just
focused so much on this it's just insane
so if you're looking at an enterprise
devices there's no scenario where
security is more important than in this
in this piece and that's been a huge
focus of ours and why does this matter
the reason why this matters obviously is
that a couple of statistics that we've
seen they've been presented to us to
various from various analysts so the
fact that 78% of business leaders just a
couple of numbers this is Google so I
got to give you some numbers 70 percent
of business leaders expect their
operations to be a digital business in
the next few years if you take a look at
the chart you already know this but if
you take a look at the chart in terms
of the growth of these mobile devices
it's insane in terms of how quickly that
so that's growing the one that I was
like to point to is ninety percent of IT
decision makers the enterprise mobility
is a critical function for customer
engagement experience and so forth I
think the more important factor that's
been lying this is probably 10% of them
have to consider maybe in a year or so
what they're gonna do with their next
job yeah quite frankly it's gotten to
the point where you need to be focused
on this type of thing or you may be
focused on something else that may be
future employment innovators across the
industry we're seeing or turning to
Android some things we'll talk about by
the way are point-of-sale and kiosk
capability and these are and again I
know you all have copies of this
presentation you will receive copies of
presentation so you can look up some of
these charts that all display here but
the growth in kiosk
if you've walked into an airport lately
right or fast food store or just about
anywhere you've actually seen in terms
of growth you know what's been happening
this marketplace the point-of-sale
is scenario is going to be a huge trend
it's going undergo a huge transformation
over the next couple of years that's
already happening with various
restaurants you've probably walked in to
various Hospital hotels resorts and so
forth we're seeing an increase in move
to Android through all of that so so we
need to be able to support that and
reduce the fragmentation that we talked
about earlier with some of the knowledge
worker scenarios in this area before it
actually happens so just to give you an
idea on the far left are the two
scenarios that that we started this
whole journey with that's the knowledge
worker devices we refer to them handsets
and tablets just accessing email
corporate data and so forth what we're
increasingly focusing on my main
objective is all these other types of
devices and we started with the rugged
devices you know for a simple reason
they most approached or looked like your
handsets right yeah if you're familiar
the zebra is the honeywell's and so
forth a lot of those devices look like
your handset they're ruggedized they
have other capabilities and and
accessories that people use to do their
jobs but they look like a smartphone and
we used
close cooperation with these vendors to
be able to build into the platform the
way to address other things you know
such as for example in a scanner in
there in the rugged device if you are a
point-of-sale system there are other
peripherals you have to connect to and
the ability to manage all of this again
going back to the fact that is you look
at these East cases you want to focus on
software and the value-add and
deliverable we need to be able to
address everything else underneath from
security tent to management and so forth
so what we really want to do at the end
of the day is allow our partners to
deliver to their customers devices for
any user no matter what they're doing
and some of the some of the particulars
areas that we see huge growth in for
example in retail as well as hospitality
we'll go into a couple of retail use
cases and a little bit but you're here
at Google cloud and when you think of a
customer journey or if you think of your
operation of your store from the time
something hits your dock in the
warehouse of the way it travels through
inventory is delivered to use at the end
of the day gets replenished these are
all ripe opportunities for a cloud
mobile scenario to be able to improve
processes insight into what's happening
and and customer experience at the end
of the day hospitality we'll talk about
a little bit in more detail as we get a
little further but the idea of being
able to interact with your guests your
customers in better ways throughout
whatever the property might be can be a
huge competitive advantage for them and
and we're working right now on how to
even go beyond what we've done in the
GMs scenario to be able to improve this
to a great extent now it's not like
people aren't building and in some of
you in the room may already be building
some applications or capabilities to
address these use cases but what this
started at was in will refer to as a OSP
that's the Android open system open
software platform sorry open source
platform the difference when I refer to
GMs versus a OSP anybody can do anything
they want with a OSP you can build
something of course you have to you know
we do a lot of things in the platform
but yeah
to build your own waste to manage the
device deliver applications so on and so
forth what we wanted to do with GMS with
play services the objective is not to
get you to take devices that have search
on it right or your Gmail I mean could
you know there could be use cases for
something like that certainly Maps and
some areas we'll talk about but really
it's Play services when we go back to
that slide I talked about with all those
applications that gets download and
think of having to update those and
address those if we leverage that to be
able to deploy these applications and
update applications to your devices that
makes your life a whole lot easier as
well as being able to utilize all the
api's to secure and manage those devices
as well everything we've built into what
we call JMS core and that's the Play
services underneath to be able to
support this and some key pieces within
that story are the ability to enhance
the security be able to deploy in a very
quick and easy way and utilize something
we call managed play so enhance security
just to give you an idea when we talk
about these types of GMs devices all
devices that have Play services on them
go through an approval process so we
understand you know what the fingerprint
is what the image looks like and we can
devise tests there don''t machine speed
constantly changing so that we can tell
even not just the fact that we do also
gain you know the apps and make sure
that there isn't you know potentially
harmful applications being delivered to
device we can tell afterwards when a
device is deployed whether it's been
routed whether it's been tampered with
whether it's still secure whether there
are problems with we can continue to
secure those devices even after the
applications been deployed device is
deployed and so forth zero touch bulk
enrollment is the capability to in in in
a summary fashion be able to take a box
take a device out of the box turn it on
sign in and everything happens you know
automatically your EMM gets attached to
it your applications get downloaded gets
booted in the fashion that you expect it
to be done all that without user
interaction we make it very easy to be
able to deploy this so so again when
you're talking in an enterprise
since the scale of thousands of devices
in multiple locations the ability to
take advantage of this and deploy apps
is critical manage Google Play again I
want to come back to the point that when
I talk about Google Play a lot of times
people think of consumer apps right
you're gonna download candy crush or
whatever onto a device manager' Google
Play means the admin the company gets to
decide exactly what's available on the
device exactly what the application
store looks like as a matter of fact you
can't open up to the world you can
publish only private apps you can
publish private apps only to your
devices you can allow a mix whatever you
decide to do and by the way you can make
it invisible to the user and just
deliver these to the devices in in a
time fashion that you choose and with
complete control for what's happening so
all this is an enterprise focus
utilizing that platform but doing it in
such a way that you have complete
control this is not you know an open to
Google open to the world a type of
scenario and by the way the one things I
always get asked about is what is Google
looking at on my devices a key thing
with manage Google Play is it's a device
account it's not a user account so we
alleviate the concern over people
wondering you know what's what's made
available what's what's what's viewed
what's what's seen and so forth now
because of all this work that we've done
when we take a look at the percentage of
devices that are free of potentially
harmful apps 99.99% of devices and and
the two bars we have here the green one
is one that is not using Google Play
only to deploy apps you know the blue
one is good using Google Play only to go
ahead and do that
the alternative by the way to do this is
a side load nap to side load nap you
have to open up your device to install
application from unknown sources and you
know utilize something called a device
in ministry or API which were
deprecating by the way this opens up
security holes that did not exist in
Android and going back to what I talked
about earlier that was a key reason we
had to close that off and deliver an
alternative so that you can actually
have this kind of result and I'll tell
you what you're the green every because
of all the
capabilities that we built into Android
to improve security you see even the
green going down dramatically but it's
worse point 5.3 percent of devices yeah
I imagine will allow your desktops you'd
be pretty happy with potentially only
five point three device you presented
those devices but you know we're not
happy with that we 1.0 one percent and
that's what we get at the end of the day
with taking advantage of this kind of
platform so it's not just making it easy
it's not making this consistent is
actually making it rock-solid secure and
I talked about rugged that's that was
the first group to actually engage with
us from the enterprise scenario we've
seen a huge trend this reported to us by
partners and analysts in terms of where
the market is going and you think about
it these types devices this comes from
an industry where people want to lock
things off from exposure to the internet
because they want to secure the device
right so in this marketplace when people
are accepting Android and moving to
Android we're winning the game because
we're we're delivering results that we
expect to you so let me talk about a
couple of things I want to start by the
way there's a couple of videos there's
only a couple that I'll actually play
there's these videos you can go to
Android comm slash Enterprise and take a
look in and see what the actual use
cases are and encourage you to do so
because they're they're pretty
interesting the innovation what people
are doing in these scenarios but an
example of what we're talking about here
and this is Walmart and they're using
zebra devices and I believe s ap is
there a cloud application that they're
delivering they've obviously you're
familiar with Walmart think about 2
million employees and what they were
faced with a scenario where they wanted
to be able to give one device to their
associates to do a number of different
things and they will look up prices they
actually scan take a look at inventory
what's available and the same Apple II
and the same device will be able to say
ok I'm out of this product
when's my delivery date right they can
see that under vice they can take a look
and see when they have ordered they can
they can start to make decisions you
know based on what trends have been you
know not just the device but from the
corporate standpoint by connecting this
to obviously a cloud app to be able to
make
decisions about when they're gonna order
what they're gonna do improving customer
journeys and so forth this is the type
of back-to-front scenario that we've
seen repeatedly in this industry this is
a really good example of it what I love
about this though is I've seen this come
up in a number of different use cases
where we're somewhat unsolicited we'll
say you know it works just like my
smartphone and if you think about it
when you're talking about doing a
transformational change transmitting
transforming any business process
getting somebody to do something a
little bit different introducing your
new product the most difficult thing is
getting somebody to accept it and be
able to learn what to do differently
than they had been before taking
advantage of a platform or we get that
reaction it's just like my smartphone
that makes your job a whole lot easier
and that's why one of the reasons people
will turn to Android to go ahead and do
this so from this perspective it's a
great use case to take a look in and see
how people are using these devices to be
able to get a 360-degree view of
everything that's happening in the
enterprise so what we've done to be able
to support all these activities is to be
able to introduce a couple of key
programs into the scenario one is what
we call android enterprise recommended
we were constantly asked what do you
recommend for an enterprise to use what
types of devices and this applies is we
eventually realized not just to a
particular phone that you're gonna use
for email but across the board to rugged
devices to EMS everything is part of the
ecosystem and we built an Android
enterprise recommended program to even
ensure that you're gonna have conference
as a customer and selecting a device
consistency and deployment and making
sure that's current up to date we have
requirements in terms of how quickly app
devices need to be upgraded is the
security updates delivered and so forth
so as well as making sure that they can
be delivering deployed with Xero touch
and all the ways that we expect to do
it's gonna look and feel the same way
much deployed obviously all these all
these capabilities are important from an
Android enterprise recommended but again
coming back to anything that you might
be doing in your particular business you
can be comfortable in the fact that
we've built the infrastructure and the
capability particularly if you choose
some of these partners
to be able to do boy things in a way
that makes a lot of sense and you can be
very comfortable with so just to take a
quick view in from the rugged
perspective by the way we started out
with five OEMs that quickly expanded
there's still a few more that are
waiting to be updated so it's been a
huge uptake and and one of the simple
reasons are is people are starting now
to make choices on particular devices
based on whether they're Androids
enterprise recommend it or not customers
always want to be comfortable with what
they're buying okay so that's a little
bit the background on what we're doing
and why we're doing it but let's talk
about some of these Android dedicated
devices and the rugged device we already
talked about but what we're doing is now
seen is we talked about more activity
and point-of-sale and better devices
kiosk scenarios and when you think about
this and all the capabilities that
Google will bring not just in terms of
device in your scenario one thing that I
didn't mention a couple of slides back
that I'll bring up now as we talk about
this because when you take a look at
this when kiosk and point-of-sale retail
is a great vertical and and when when
you think back to you what you do
particularly in a retail segment
you know aspects to your business one
things I mention a few slides back is
other Google technologies you know one
cue is augmented reality so imagine if
you will a scenario where you could take
a device and you were in a warehouse to
be able to walk through and use on
augmented reality for anyone who wants
to pick something to be able to go
immediately to that shelf or to be able
to walk to a scenario where you're
fixing a component and to be able to
have overlaid not only instructions on
what to fix maybe it's actually because
you've already captured information
about which device is failing you know
what needs to be done so forth the
device can actually lead you to
understand what you need to do in which
device needs to be replaced all of which
by the way exists right now and those
are use cases people are delivering so
you can build that type of capability
into into your scenario so how are some
of the dedicated device is being used
and in full disclosure this particular
slide is actually an example but I stole
it from the chrome guys because this was
actually a chrome deployment you can do
same thing in Android well you may not
be aware of is there a proximity API and
all these devices so if you have an
application maybe your retailer and you
have an application might be a loyalty
app and and some ways actually opted in
to be able to get offers or you know
notices from you is they walk by a
particular display that could be geared
to be able to deliver to them either
content offers and so forth would apply
to that individual so these are the
types of things that actually if it's
done in the right way can be really
compelling any user experience so Crona
post is a delivery company based in
Paris similar to a FedEx UPS and so
forth and a while back they decided that
they need to revamp their fleet they're
delivering about a million packages a
day and they saw a lot of inefficiencies
throughout the whole scenario from being
able to track what devices are picked up
to scheduling routes and and so forth
what they often do is they work for the
partner zebra and one of her human
partners to be able to design a system
whereby they would be able to have a
driver
number one when walks in in in the
morning do we have pick a device up drop
it into his truck or her truck and it's
got the map laid out it's got all its
delivery schedule already set up for him
he just has to follow you know what the
device is telling him to do and that's
all driven by an application that
understands you know what are the
packages where the locations what is
traffic in the area you know other
disruptions to a particular route and
you can and they use Google Maps to do a
lot of this in addition to what they're
doing on device and their own
application and if you're not aware of
their API is that you can build other
capabilities into Google Maps so for
example if you're a delivery driver
maybe you have a particular address but
the loading dock happens to be around
the corner on another physical address
or in my end it might be a little bit
difficult to get to have to pick a
scenario you can build that into the app
so that when the driver is approaching
his destination that driver is going to
the correct area navigating with the
right Street makes it a much more
efficient capability to be able to
deliver those devices so you
it's been a huge success in their in
their deployment and not only in terms
of helping the drivers but is they're
capturing all the information about
what's happening what are the routes you
know what are the failures and the
trucks and so forth there's a loads of
information that produce analytics that
they can use to dictate and determine
how they want to make changes and what
they want to deploy in going forward
Marks and Spencer you may be familiar
with a big retailer in in the UK they
worked with a partner Honeywell to to
say you know what we want to build a
device of the future what what these
solicits were doing is they would have
been described doing five or six devices
one is to check a price you wanted to
see what's in the inventory one is to
understand you know customers order
status you know so on and so forth they
decided they would take one device and
instead of having all these different
devices do things they would have one
device that has apps to run all these
different capabilities they spent a lot
of time actually working with their
associates to understand how they do
their daily job what's what's problems
what's you know what's headaches and so
forth and they rolled this about a year
ago you know out to their customers and
it's really interesting when you listen
to the video the the woman that was
actually hitting this up says this is I
don't know how long she'd been it Marcin
Spencer but this is probably the most
successful rollout that they ever had
you listen to some of the associates
talking about how great it is to have
this device in their pocket that makes
their lives that much easier what a
results in at the end of the day they
have statistics they talked about in the
video we're an improved customer
satisfaction as well as employee
satisfaction to a market degree and it
all can be traced to when they roll this
program out so so there's hard data in
terms of how this makes an actual
difference not just to your customers at
the end of the day but but the employees
as well most of you are probably
familiar with Pitney Bowes postage meter
company Pitney Bowes a while back
decided that you know what we need to
change our focus a little bit we need to
incorporate some of the new mobile
capabilities we need to deliver things
to our customers in a different
we want to deliver capabilities they
just don't have today so what they did
is they worked with us they built a
postage meter that has an embedded
seven-inch tablet in it and what they
deliver to their users I'm not sure if
you're familiar they're the background
but all these are regulated so if you if
you find a postage meter and a customer
account it's not nobody owns it that's
all managed by Pitney Bowes but what
they do is they deliver a webstore so
that the customers can buy certain
services go well beyond weighing a
package and making a delivery you're
part of that is an application that
would do the calculation for the
customer to say listen here's a package
going to X location it's Y weight use
FedEx or use UPS or they choose the most
efficient or at least expensive way to
go and deliver that package there are
other capabilities that people use on a
daily basis that could be used on this
device ranging from things like
inventory timesheets and so forth so a
device that you think of as very simple
your way a package you ship it can
actually be changed and and used to be
able to deliver capabilities to
end-users that previously you won't be
able to deliver so my cab is a company
that's based in the Philippines and they
have a ride-sharing application they're
taking I'm sure a lot of people in in
this room are familiar with lyft or uber
and what you know what you get with your
app to be able to rate understand who's
coming to get you what they what the
reality is so so imagine taking that
type of capability and what they did was
they apply that to the taxicab industry
so it's all taxi cabs as opposed to over
a lift but what they have is you can
think of three devices one is the
drivers device that's that sits in the
front of the cab and it's generally a
smartphone type of form factor that
allows them to you know get new
customers understand you know what the
route is to the customer destination and
so forth a device that's more tablet
sized is in the backseat and that's used
to do everything from display
entertainment they have some ads
capabilities they allow the customer to
pay on that device and of course that's
all connected via nap to the customers
device so all this is tied together
and what when you think about this it
sounds kind of simple in a it's a it's a
taxicab app it allows you to understand
that you know who your drivers gonna be
getting the right cab it's gonna be
well-maintained and so forth but think
about it they're using these devices to
make their payment right so they have to
be absolutely secure so it's just a
matter of making it available absolutely
secure and it has to work because if
it's not working we don't take payments
and everything falls apart so this is
kind of an innovative way of taking what
we've learned in other areas applying it
to an existing business to kind of
transform and make it more up-to-date in
terms of what customers expect and I
want to play a short clip here in terms
of what the customer is looking for and
what they saw is advantages about the
platform as well as the partners they
were working with the key piece that
they wanted to talk about and again this
is on the website so you can go and
listen to them tell it in their words
but they've got thousands of devices
that are deployed you know and there's
new cabs coming online and so forth they
have to be doing they have to do this
remotely they have to be able to do it
easily they have to do an automated
fashion they can't send someone out to
all these different locations to be able
to set it up and deploy the devices all
of this is managed by the platform
that's built into Android Play services
and of course as I mentioned Security's
absolutely critical so they talked a
little bit in detail in the presentation
as to as to why they chose that and what
the impact was singing Pino is anybody
here from the UK by the way no okay
young Pingo is a company based in London
that goes to restaurants and delivers a
service whereby at the end of a meal
they deliver a folder along with your
bill that includes a device it looks
like five and a half inch smartphone
it's not a smartphone it's actually
running one app and that app is to be
able to rate your experience to be able
to rate you know how the server was
cleanliness of the the restaurant how
the food was the different dishes and so
forth of course it's got all the detail
because it's time to the order that was
delivered
and they've had unbelievable response
from customers in terms of ravenous
everybody seems to want to go ahead and
rate the app and what's what's important
about it it's not only can they get if
you kind of TripAdvisor type scenario or
Yelp and so forth ratings of that
particular restaurant thing and publish
they can advertise and so forth but they
get really critical information about
what's happening across all of their
enterprise it could be it could be a
small restaurant chain of three
different locations but if if one dish
is greater to them and really lousy it
at one or service is the you know the
same way it's important to know that
right it's important to get that kind of
information there's loads of other more
detail you can get out of this type of
application and when you think about
that and you're thinking of various
applications that matter to your
particular industry that type of
analytical approach and data gathering
would be critical in terms of what what
you can actually deliver so as far as
the use cases I'm going to close with
Lausanne this is actually my favorite
and you know this is this is I had to
have it rhyme right so it's inspiration
innovation and celebration at the end of
the day but the point I want to make
here is if you're looking at enterprise
use cases and you're looking at what you
want to do obviously there's a scenario
do you think can be improved or that you
can think can be deliver capabilities
that's not not previously done the
important thing is to focus on what is
that inspiration what is that key use
case because you can innovate using the
platform to do some amazing things
you're gonna celebrate at the end of the
day but hopefully the honor is gonna
work on this next one because I want to
lead into it with an example of that
inspiration so Samantha no friend I
don't give the voice over here travel to
Brazil a while ago on vacation and the
interesting thing about Brazil if you
know anything about Brazil is nobody
speaks English there nobody speaks
anything but Portuguese as a matter of
fact okay so a few people maybe but what
what actually ended up happening is some
a third friend walked in
to various restaurants and would try to
order a nest does anyone speak English
in the answer of course was always no
and of course not being able to
communicate means that you can't order
anything so at the end of the day what
intro happen is they walked out of 11
restaurants over the course of the time
and we're not able to order in any of
them they returned to the States
and by this time they were really hungry
so the first thing they do is go to a
restaurant to be able to order something
and a way to bring some a menu it takes
their order understands what they want
walks up to the cash register the
point-of-sale device enters it in and at
that point in time the inspiration
strikes and so Samantha sells to a
friend you know wouldn't it be great if
I had a mobile tablet instead of a paper
tablet right and I'd be able to
understand what I want and order it and
by the way maybe I speak English maybe
I'm in Brazil but I would be able to
order in English so that I understand
what ends up happening in the kitchen is
they get the order in whatever their
local language is and they be able to
prepare the food deliver to the table
and everything is good yeah everything
is wonderful so taking advantage of this
type of mobile application can deliver
scenario where you've got less mistakes
faster service efficient staff and of
course increase your revenue and from
that standpoint that's urban
translations was born so what what
actually happens this was the scenario
of a restaurant or in translations has
done a lot of work not only in
restaurants but hotels and resorts to be
able to deliver capabilities such
there's no just ordering food right
imagine when you walk into a hotel and
in your room is a particular device that
ends up being your digital concierge and
maybe you're ordering food in pretty low
location maybe you're asking for certain
services maybe you want to find out
locations to go to to be able to
communicate in your own language and to
be able to have that seamless and allow
us to interact it obviously helps the
customer but it helps helps the staff as
well and even if it's not a scenario
where you have to do a translation the
ability to walk in and have a key
just in you know I marry it down the
street for example so that you know
what's that I don't even know I think
it's enterprise car commercial right
where the guy says well yeah I don't
have to talk to somebody else I want to
I don't want to all right I'm kind of
that guy by the way
so the idea to be able to just interact
with the device and get what you want is
kind of appealing to me so these are the
types of things that even on something
as simple as you can't find someone to
take your order or talk to you can lead
to this inspiration that allows you to
focus on on new innovative scenarios so
so the key at the end of the day
innovate right we've got a platform that
would allow you to do it multiple form
factors multiple sizes multiple price
points all these things exist in the
android scenario these are devices that
you can use you can buy them off the
shelf there there are companies that
will work with you to private label
devices regardless of what that form
factor happens to be we can help connect
you with those so that you can build
these devices there be anything from a
kiosk to to an order system and so forth
at the end of the day yes you're getting
you productive employees you're really
getting happy customers but you're
delivering something that makes your
business succeed and thrive and that's
the type of thing that we want to
deliver with Android we'll help you do
so I've encouraged you to take a look at
this I want to work with you so if we
can help you do some of this I'll be
more than happy to engage myself or some
of the team members to actually deliver
some of this
[Music]